welcome back to 8701
um so in this second chapter chapter
number one
we start talking about quarks and
leptons interactions and fears
and we'll start by very general
discussion of quantum fields and matter
so you all know that what we mean by
particles and forces in a classical
sense
however we need now to see how they
connect with quantum fields
and how this helps us to consider matter
and forces
in a very similar way
the modern view of the basic way that
particles come to exist
is in terms of quantized spheres which
is
an extension of the quantum mechanics
you love and know
um which you have done before where you
quantize
particles these fields have quantum
equations
for the field amplitudes which are
basically like
the quantum simple harmonic oscillator
but there are an infinite number of them
one
for every possible frequency of wave in
the field
this means the amplitudes for the wave
for each frequency are therefore
quantized
in integer steps uh just like
a simple harmonic oscillator this is
what we see as a particle the first
excitation gives one particle of a
frequency
a further excitation of the amplitude
for the same frequency corresponds to
two particles
etc etc so hence the concept of quantum
field unlike normal quantum mechanics
allows an arbitrary
and changeable number of particles to
exist
this is necessary as you will see later
such that we can create and annihilate
part particles
in reactions in the decays
and the standard wave functions
correspond to an equation of a
particular frequency
amplitude when it is exist and existed
so now just let's consider a few cases
here um
um imagine you have you know two
particles two fermions for example let's
say two electrons
um and you consider the wave function um
quantum field theory um actually says
that there's only
one electron quantum field for the whole
universe and every electron
which has this is due to an excitation
of the field
and all electrons are identical in a
quantum mechanical sense
and they all arise from the same field
now the theory says then that our
particular properties or the resulting
black equations namely their symmetry
under exchange of these particles
so the actual symmetry um depends on
whether or not the particle is a fermion
which means it has been one half or
three halves or
five halves etc or boson which means
that it has been one
zero one or two and so on so for any
identical fermion an electron a quantum
field
theory says that their wave function
must invade
the property of anti-symmetry
um this means that when we write an
overall wave function and we replace two
particles
to pick up a minus sign uh this property
is just
not just for for for electrons but for
all fermions
um that's all metaparticle as the
smaller shoot
so it also holds for composite particles
a composite spin half particle
um is subject to the same antisymmetry
this probably property of exchange
antisymmetry leads to a well-known
um principle namely the pauli principle
which means that you cannot have two
electrons of the same
energy state or the same state um
because when you would actually
swap them you find
that they're identical which means
there's dark contrast to the actual
description of this wave function so
this doesn't really work and therefore
two electrons or two fermions cannot be
in the same state
in very general constructing a
wave function or a total wave equation
for two firms is not that hard
you can simply do this by
by this construction
uh important additional statement on
note to take here is that an
anti-particle such as a positron
is not identical to a particle um
such that the electron again
if you move on to bosons both on
exchange is symmetric
meaning that you know if you replace two
bosons defines identical
wave function and then constructing a
two boson
uh total wave function you do this by
adding those two functions together this
is by definition
the metric let's move now forwards to
exchange particles again you have a very
good idea of the classical picture
how forces are transmitted um so the
modern picture however
of how a force acts under conservation
is by admission and by absorption of a
particle
what is shown in this diagram here where
you let's say you have an electron and a
second electron
they see each other and they see each
other by emitting
and absorbing photons and you see this
here so
this electron comes along maybe emitting
a photon
this electron here emits it and by this
exchange of emission
and absorption of photon those two
particles the electrostatic electrons
see each other
for this you know you can think about
like you know two ships
shooting cannons if you want but this
would all um
um but you also have to consider that
there is not just repelling forces but
also
attracting forces could have replaced
the electron with the positron and the
negative
negative the negative and the positive
charge attracting each other
this is it for this uh for this short um
basically an intro into the intro of the
intro um
i hope you enjoy this all of this
concept we go into more detail
this is really just the starting point
um and in the next lecture you'll see
how we can actually understand
aspects of this diagram here which we
call the final diagram
you